ローションの直線を作りました
あの・・・
滑りたくて
人間で滑っても、かなり多分滑ると思うんですけども
一体何を使って滑れば
一番ローションの上で滑るのかっていうのを
ちょっと今回検証していきたいと思います
まずは一回、人間で！
このローションの上を滑ると何ｍぐらい滑るのか、
で、その後いろんな物を試してみて、何の道具とかね、
物を使った時に、ローションの上で一番滑るのかを
ちょっと今日は検証していきたいと思います。
では行こう！
助走をつけてから行くので、ここがスタートです
ここスタートにして・・・
こう行って・・・
で、ここからスタートです
ここからスタートして、
どこまで滑れるか
ちょっとやってみようと思います！
うっわ
ぱちゃぱちゃぱちゃ
僕は・・・多分なんですけど、
30mはいくんじゃないかと。思います。
うっし！
行きます！
スタッフ）3
スタッフ）2
スタッフ）1
スタッフ）スタート！
たったったったった
バチャ！！ズザァァァァァァァァーー
スタッフ）7ｍです
スタッフ）3
スタッフ）2
スタッフ）1
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
シュザァァァァァァァァァ
あぁ！痛い…
あっ　でも…
来たっしょ！？
スタッフ）結果
ハイ
スタッフ）17m70cmです
ゴフッ
え？マ・・・マシじゃね？結構
スタッフ）ちょ、その動きヤバ・・・
人間の記録で１７ｍちょいだったんで、
次は、いろんな物を使って
この記録を超えれるかどうかを
ちょっと検証していきたいと思います
ちょっと、季節的にソリが売ってなかったので、
ソリっぽい物を、ホームセンターで買ってきました
ドン！！
っし！
これもう飛び乗る感じですね
これで助走つけて・・・
飛び込んで、中に入って、このまま滑って行く
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
シュザァァァァァッ
ボンッ！！
痛ぁぁぁぁぁぁ！
アア、アア、痛ぇ、痛ぇ！足足足足…
痛ぃ、痛、痛、痛
グキシッ！！（効果音です）
ゴキシッ！！（同じく）
浮き輪でございます。
膝を置いて、丁度ベストな感じで、行けそうなので
これをちょっと足にひいてこのまま滑ってみようと思います
持って、走って行って、「バッ」て置いて
乗った方が多分いけると思う
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
シュザァァァァァ
ボンッ！！パチャッ！！
アァーーーーーーー！！
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
ボンッ！！シュザァァァァァ
スタッフ）結果
スタッフ）3m10cmです
うるせぇ！！
あ！　あるよコレ！
あ！あるあるあるある！
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
シュ―　ドテッ　ス――
ほらもうコレ、ちょっとこういう感じになっちゃ…
コンッ
もう失格だわ…
スタッフ）えぇ～
滑らないもん、だって！
ほら！
スタッフ）それでやってみよう？
ムリだよ！
スタッフ）やってみることに意味があるって！
じゃ、ここに止まります！
マジでやんのかコレ・・・
スタッフ）3
スタッフ）2
スタッフ）1
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
シュザァァァァ～
ドン！！
イィヤァ～～！！
スタッフ）3
スタッフ）2
スタッフ）1
スタッフ）スタート！
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
あぁ！！ズボンが！ズボン・・・
ヒャッ・・・
スタッフ）3
スタッフ）2
スタッフ）1
スタッフ）スタート！
ちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃちゃちゃちゃちゃ
チュザァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァァ
ウアアァッ！
スタッフ）結果は…
スタッフ）20メートル30センチ！！
ウッシャァァァ！！！
♪~ED~♪
ぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃぱっちゃ
ピチャッピチャッピチャッ
ウァッ
ウァッ！
たったったったったっ
チュザァァァァァァァ